as the rapidly spreading and coronavirus
continues to take its toll on the global
economy jobs are quickly disappearing
it's perhaps no coincidence that the
cryptocurrency industry finds itself on
a hiring spree while so many others are
having to let go of employees blockchain
and cryptocurrency startups were founded
from day one for this and they seem to
be prepared for remote workers in a
recent conversation I had with the CEO
of crack and one of the largest
exchanges in the United States we
learned that they were hiring not only
for technology professionals but for
professionals with a wide range of skill
sets qualified not only from the
hospitality industry and elsewhere but
for those with liberal arts education we
found ourselves literally letting our
air down as we talk crypto I think we
saw some some people that saw this
coming maybe they were following the
news out of Wuhan they were already
hedging and then we saw once the news
really started to break that we were
getting a lot of new signups it's kind
of been a bit of a ramp up just over the
last few weeks every day more signups
every day more verification request more
people funding their accounts and that
to us is like the signal that things are
heating up that we need to start adding
more staff and actually the the whole
kovat 19 thing as terrible as it has
been for the broader economy actually a
lot of our employees have partners or
other members of their household who are
now unemployed and the timing is is
worked out well for us and that we
suddenly have an increase in demand and
we a lot of roles to fill the majority
of open positions are less technical
customer service compliance
documentation so we're able to offer
temporary work to to our employees other
family members based on what you're
seeing looking around right now how
would you categorize this bitcoins
relationship with traditional markets
yeah I think there's some there's some
correlation because I think there's some
common denominator and and that is
retail investors who are basically
gamblers they they make their trades on
a whim
they follow the market and I think
what it is no matter what their
quote-unquote investing in they're
buying on the way up and they're
panicked selling as soon as you know
something goes wrong but we've seen
Bitcoin rebound you know 30 percent plus
in the last week it's still up 65
percent on the year I think we're seeing
a little bit of that you know maybe
deleveraging and maybe people selling
selling some of their assets to cover
other positions in the equities markets
or to make sure they've got enough cash
to handle whatever's coming all the
volatility the ups and downs the
craziness in the markets if you've been
living in Bitcoin for any amount of time
you know you've just you're used to this
level of volatility you just live your
life on the roller coaster and what's
happening in Bitcoin now is not that
extreme for Bitcoin you know it's it's
what's happening in the rest of the
world that seems very extreme by
comparison and you know it's a terrible
time for the world but by all
measurements I'm cracking as the
business is doing well and I think that
the cryptocurrency space as a whole is
doing well in this situation
[Music]